welcome to google cloud next on air
in this session we'll be discussing
major league baseball's data warehouse
modernization journey
i'm ryan mcdowell cloud data engineer
from google and joining me today is rob
goretzky
vp of data engineering at major league
baseball
today we'll be taking a look at general
migration strategy for
cloud data warehouse migrations and then
deep dive into
how and why major league baseball moved
their data warehouse to bigquery
starting off with the overall strategy
of data warehouse migrations to the
cloud
we've heard from our customers that
traditional data warehouses are causing
tons of pain as they are unable to keep
up with today's analytic demand
there's tremendous complexity with
scaling on demand
and this is compounded by the inability
of their incumbent technology to keep up
with data growth
traditional data warehouses were built
for batch paradigms
and not for today's world where by 2025
about one-fourth of data will be
streaming in nature
access restrictions and data silos on
premise inhibit data sharing and
collaboration
existing legacy solutions have the
inability
to take advantage of emerging
technologies such as ai
in real time and you need to move data
out of your data warehouse into complex
fragile or niche systems that require
phds to operate
finally legacy data warehouses are
extremely expensive to purchase and
maintain
so how does bigquery address these
challenges bigquery allows you to store
vast amounts of data with bigquery
telegraph media group reduce their query
time from
hours to minutes with up to four
terabytes of data processed
in less than one minute blue apron
streams 140 million events per day with
bigquery
this has helped them accelerate business
decisions by one day
to near real time to better manage food
inventory and delivery home depot is
able to empower business units
to create their own bigquery projects
and reduce dependency on it budgeting
for additional data warehouse capacity
20th century fox uses bigquery to run
analytics to pull data from doubleclick
in youtube and uses tensorflow to do
audience analysis
on film scripts and track content
patterns that may
better predict what resonates with
audiences
hsbc needed to cost effectively upgrade
their aging territory environment
and across multiple regulatory
jurisdictions
by moving to bigquery they're able to
save millions over seven years
so how should you be thinking about your
data warehouse modernization strategy
this diagram shows a high level legacy
architecture from before the migration
it illustrates the catalog of available
data sources
legacy data pipelines legacy operational
pipelines and feedback loops
additionally legacy bi reports and the
dashboards that are
accessed by your end users in order to
migrate a legacy data warehouse
architecture to bigquery
we first need to go about decomposing
the migration such that we aren't left
with a
risky big bang cut over at google cloud
we generally think about data warehouse
migrations through the lens of the
following framework
first through cloud foundations where we
set the foundational cloud
infrastructure including network
i am and security then risk assessment
and mitigation where we evaluate
the operational risk of the migration
and then develop detailed mitigation
plans
third the migration where we actually
execute the migration
comprising of various steps then change
management and learning
setting up a center of excellence within
your organization such that
when the new environment is cut over
users are confident from day one
during the migration we generally
approach it from an iterative standpoint
first we'll assassin plan the migration
based on the source environment
and design the destination environment
then we'll work through an iterative
process
going workload by workload or subject
area by subject area
where we work on migrating those
workloads from the source system to the
destination system
this generally comprises of enterprise
setup and security mapping
migrating schema and data using bigquery
dts
translating queries using some of our
partner tools
migrating business apps migrating
upstream pipelines
verification and validation to ensure
that once the environment is cut over
that users are getting the same results
on top of the same data sets that they
had
when they had on their source system
performance tuning
and then of course report and scale
testing
now i'll turn it over to rob to take us
through how major league baseball
completed their migration journey
thank you ryan my name's rob goretsky
and i'm the vp of data engineering at
major league baseball
today i'm going to talk about major
league baseball's migration from
teradata to bigquery
including the motivations for migration
the actual migration process itself
and the capabilities we unlocked when we
completed this migration
so as a bit of a background i oversee
the fan data engineering and business
intelligence teams at major league
baseball
we work with fan transaction and
interaction data generated by internally
developed applications
including mlb.com and the 30 major
league baseball club websites
and our mlb and ballpark apps and third
party
sites such as ticketmaster tickets.com
stubhub and fanatics
my team doesn't work directly with
player stats or on field data such as
statcast
that's the domain of our baseball data
team at major league baseball
but we do work with the more traditional
user engagement data to ensure that we
understand our fans and can bring them
closer to the game of baseball
this includes personalizing and
targeting marketing and fan experiences
on our website
and on our apps and sharing our
centralized data with all 30 major
league baseball clubs
in our project known as wheelhouse
we have over 350 data pipelines that
have been developed
over the last 10 plus years most of our
data sets are not what i'd consider to
be really
big data for example a data set
containing every ticket sale
only contains about 80 million rows per
year for a couple hundred gigabytes of
data
that said we do have a few very large
data sets um
generated by user interactions on our
website and apps
these are highly trafficked and we
collect every user interaction and store
it in our data warehouse platform
in addition many of the medium-sized
data sets such as ticket sales
turn out to be pretty complicated in
terms of the modeling and validation
due to the various ways fans can
purchase exchange
resell transfer and ultimately share and
use these items
before our migration to bigquery we use
teradata as our data warehouse platform
we ran data pipelines using informatica
and airflow
mlb employees can access teradata
directly by connecting using sql and
using our bi platform looker
but we didn't have a means to open up
access directly to teradata for all 30
major league baseball clubs
without major performance and security
implications so we set up airflow
pipelines to essentially copy data
from teradata to s3 in 30 separate files
one per club
per data set to allow clubs to access
that data via s3 and athena
this setup presented several challenges
the major challenge was sharing data
with clubs
was that we were copying data so when
we're copying data you need to properly
identify which data has changed each day
if you want to do an incremental copy
and this was challenging in cases where
we had late arriving data
or corrections to make to the data that
happened often after the fact
which was especially common with our
ticketing data sets um
in addition if we wanted to evolve the
schema that we shared with clubs either
by adding fields or changing data types
that often would then require us to
recopy all historical data out to the
club which can be time consuming and
error-prone itself
in addition if we had a correction to
make we often would need to circulate
that on a change log so that clubs would
be aware that we've made a change to the
data
that they should refetch perhaps older
data files that we had published
um this process was also very much a
one-way street
clubs didn't have a way to share data
back with us in a way that we could
easily query
and that would automatically set up
schemas for us to work with
um as our data sources started to become
more and more real time
another issue with this setup was that
the system to share data was itself
batch based
so even if we were ingesting data in
real time to share the data back with
clubs involved making a copy
perhaps every hour or even more
frequently every five minutes
but we never really hit a real-time
cadence where clubs could see the data
as it happened
um other major challenges outside of the
data sharing
with working with teradata included the
operational support overhead
we maintained a full-time dba team who
helped us with the traditional dba tasks
such as
resolving performance issues monitoring
for database deadlocks and long-running
queries
resolving backup issues and we spent a
lot of time and effort trying to
continue to refine that part of the
system
when really that wasn't our core concern
our core concern was ultimately
providing
business data analytics to our
organization
with respect to performance we often
found that in spite of our best
efforts to implement proper workload
management and tuning
we often would have one bad apple
spoiling the bunch a single
well-intentioned user query
that ate up the entire spool space or
otherwise brought the system to its
knees
was fairly common and something that we
had to deal with all the time
um another issue as we started looking
at scaling our system on teradata was
that
the compute and storage were tightly
coupled this meant that if we wanted to
consider bringing in some of the very
very large data sets such as our
clickstream
we couldn't do so without also linearly
increasing our compute
which came at much additional cost that
perhaps didn't make sense for us overall
um furthermore we found that integration
with third-party tools and apps was
limited
when we were looking to integrate with
new bi platforms or data science tools
or analytics tools
often their support for teradata was
mediocre at best
so we ran a project to fully migrate
terry data from bigquery
from may through november 2019 so we ran
this entire project in about seven
months time
at a high level the work involved
setting up data replications from
teradata to bigquery
and then iterating through the
conversion of etl jobs and reports
we needed to continue to support live
reporting and agreed
that a big bang cutover happening all at
once was not going to be feasible or
desirable for us
we instead wanted to take things in
chunks and ensure that along the way we
were validating that bigquery was
performing as expected
and that data was loading properly and
matching up with our expectations
so in order to determine the order in
which to attack
converting and migrating all of our etl
jobs
we built a dependency map that took a
look at which tables and etl jobs were
upstream and downstream from each other
jobs that were less entangled because
they were on the leaf nodes in this
diagram
had fewer downstream dependencies and
therefore could be migrated first
so we worked outside in if you will on
this diagram where we took those things
that had the fewest downstream
dependencies
um migrated them first and then
continued to work our way inwards
we set up hundreds of replication jobs
using apache airflow very early on in
our project
and throughout the project as needed as
new tables arose
one of the more time-consuming tasks
about this was determining exactly which
upstream process
we should wait for before replicating
data to bigquery but we consider this
critical for our success
because we wanted bigquery to be as
close as possible to being a perfect
match of what was in teradata
so for example if we get a daily load of
stubhub data
and that arrived into teradata at nine
o'clock am
we were hoping that we could have it in
bigquery by 901 am
so this is not a hot hot replication
it's not necessarily what you might
consider a real time replication
but it was basically close enough that
all of our analysts data scientists
report builders
bi team could immediately start using
bigquery very early on in the project
for all of their new work this ensured
basically that all the data was
essentially in bigquery as fresh as it
was in teradata
so as a result of this carefully timed
setup for replication
these data stakeholder teams were able
to start developing new queries and
processes on bigquery very early on
this was great because otherwise if
teams were continuing to build
new work on teradata during the seven
month migration
we might have another seven months worth
of migration to do afterwards and we
might never finish the project
so it was important for us that we could
sort of draw a line in the sand and say
to all of these stakeholder teams
only build new things on bigquery we're
going to replicate all the data you need
to work on your process so for example
for the data science team we're going to
make sure that all the ticket sales data
that you need
to do predictive analytics is there in
bigquery so it's going to look and feel
just like it does on teradata
um but be available to you at the same
time so that everything new you build
today you can start building on bigquery
in the back end we continued migrating
the etl jobs themselves
by simply having replication and unlock
the ability for most teams to think
about bigquery as a live production
system right away
as we converted etl jobs having
replication in place also allowed us to
ensure
that we could do table validation and
match results between the result of
output from teradata and bigquery
so in order to proceed with etl
conversion we focused on developing a
recipe that can be followed
by data engineers without them having
advanced knowledge
of any of the business or domain logic
that were contained within that pipeline
so we started off looking at steps that
can be automated
and we spend some time upfront
developing tooling to automate those
processes
for example we wrote shellers python
scripts that would simply pull pieces of
sql
out of parts of our code so that we
could quickly identify which pieces
needed to be translated
we also looked for cases where there
were teradata specific function calls or
teradata specific
commands being issued and we were able
to pull those out and kind of translate
those in mass
so this meant that for the first month
or so of our project we weren't
necessarily doing an end-to-end etl
conversion just yet
but we were kind of building out the
tools that would enable us to then move
very quickly through all of the others
so once we got through building out a
lot of the automation the remaining
steps was a majority of the project and
it was done by our data engineers
this involved places where either it was
too difficult to build automation for
something
or because we wanted to have validation
done by a human
who could look over something and ensure
that it passed proper sanity checks
um also working with informatica we
found that there was no easy way to
automate
you know mass changes so a lot of those
involved clicking through the interface
and just manually making changes in the
gui
so with respect to automated components
one tool that helped us immensely was a
sql transpiler tool
by a company called compilerworks this
tool accepts
teradata sql as input and then outputs
bigquery sql
so while minor sql differences such as
function name changes or
small syntax changes could have been
resolved by a simple regex search and
replace
more complex cases involves having a
deeper understanding of the sql
structure and the data types that
underlie them
here's a really common case that we had
that used the teradata specific qualify
clause
the compilerworks tool was able to pull
the clause used within qualify
and rewrite the query as an inner query
doing this at hand would have been
error-prone at best
another major advantage we found when
using the compilerworks tool
is that it became aware of the actual
schema itself including the data types
so bigquery is pretty specific about
data types for example if a field
has a data type of integer it may not
allow you to directly insert a numeric
value without casting it to an integer
uh teradata was a bit more lacks about
this so this is the kind of thing that a
translation normally would trip up on
time and time again
the compiler works as tool being aware
of the data type of a column
when it parsed and read the sql it was
actually able to automatically apply the
proper cast or conversion statement to
it for us
so that the syntax would be valid and
would run immediately
when we were done converting an etl
pipeline we continue running the
original pipeline entire data
but we'd run the converted pipeline side
by side in a prod parallel environment
in this diagram here we see the airflow
dag diagram
of our original etl with teradata
operators embedded within
and on the right hand side we see the
exact same pipeline with bigquery
operators embedded within
and we set these up to run in two
separate environments but at generally
the same time of day with the same input
data
so that we could basically do a
side-by-side check that the output data
would match
to further assist us with this table
validation we looked in the marketplace
for tools that would essentially allow
us to run a diff between two tables
similar to how you run a diff when
you're using gif git to look at a
code review or pull request reviews we
couldn't find anything that fit our
needs exactly in terms of allowing us to
do
a table to table comparison um by
joining on the primary key
and then telling us if rows were missing
from one table or another
or if rows had fields that differed in
one table or another so we built our own
tool
our own tool essentially ran queries and
generated sql for us
on bigquery to take the output of the
replicated teradata etl
and compare that with the output of the
bigquery etl
this would quickly surface to us if
there were either differences
in the row count or in rows missing on
one side or the other
or if there were field differences at
this point this was one of the few
pieces of the project that really
required domain and analyst expertise
because if the diff tool showed
differences and it often would show some
differences
we need to make a business decision
about whether those differences in the
output were relevant for our use case
for example if there was a field that
simply had a created date or a time
stamp
we would expect those would be slightly
different between teradata and bigquery
simply because of the slightly different
runtime when those jobs completed
however if there was a field such as a
financial charge value
we would expect that generally those
should match up exactly
so if there was a difference in those
and it was significant we would need to
dig in further to see where in the
pipeline
something was either mistranslated or
something perhaps was uh thrown off for
some other reason
so having a tool like this allowed us to
have the data engineers spit out
conformed output that then we could pass
to analysts and end users
and more experienced users of the
business analytics side
to help us understand what the
differences were
so taking a look again at sort of where
we went we took a look before
at our data architecture before our
bigquery migration
including this middle layer where we had
um landing data
as a copy for club data access in our
wheelhouse project
after bigquery migration you see that
we've removed that middle layer
completely
consumers of data whether they are at
clubs
outside of our network or internal users
or our data science or other constituent
teams are all looking at the exact same
copy of the data there is not
a second copy made of any data this
means that if we load data in real time
it's available to those consumers in
real time
and it also means that we don't have to
deal with all the discrepancies that
arise by making copies of data
so we mentioned a few of the benefits
here and we're going to summarize them
here
with respect to democratization of data
i will do a live demo here in a few
moments
to show how we could use the bigquery
tools to very easily share data
and securely ensure that we only share a
subset of data with the proper
stakeholders
with respect to performance and scale we
saw that
some of our large queries had a 50
reduction in runtime without really
any additional work done on our end and
similarly we saw that certain data sets
such as our click stream data
which consist of over 300 terabytes a
year in uncompressed data
were able to be loaded into bigquery
whereas previously we couldn't even
consider doing something like that
so we instead needed to keep really
large data sets like those in separate
silos within a hadoop ecosystem to
process them
having them all in one place was one of
the single biggest user requests that we
had gotten
because users often want to join the
click stream data with other data sets
such as our ticketing or shop data
for security instead of having to have
separate user rights and roles and
credentials
all of this is centrally managed by our
infosec team by way of our integration
with octa and g suite
so users are set up with groups within
octa and those flow automatically into g
suite which then flows automatically
into bigquery roles and responsibilities
this means we don't have to have any
time spent on setting passwords worrying
about
who has compromised access who might
otherwise leave the organization
all of it is set up centrally in one
place
um developer happiness is really a key
one for me and my team
in that we just found that everybody who
worked with the system sort of
understood things right away with it and
generally had less gotchas than what
they did with teradata
um more specifically we found that one
of the biggest advantages is that we can
often
google if we're not sure about exactly
how to do something and find a helpful
stack overflow answer almost right away
this wasn't necessarily the case with
teradata uh which was generally the
domain of um
enterprise companies and larger
customers and really wasn't as widely
available
to the masses as something like bigquery
is where with bigquery there's a free
tier that you know any engineer can jump
in and try
things out with it it just means that
there's a wider mind share for it it
means that there's more documentation
and more community support for it
we find that helpful time and time again
uh with respect to features we're
finding that features are consistently
added that help us out
without breaking anything for us and
without requiring any downtime for
upgrades
um with teradata we were sort of pinned
to a specific version for several years
at a time
because an upgrade was a major process i
mean for us
with bigquery we just take a look at our
system one morning and we see release
notes and there's new features
and it's like opening a goodie bag you
immediately have some new toys to play
with every day
um so with respect to flexibility uh we
found that early on
um in our testing we didn't want to make
a big commitment about going with
bigquery
but we love that we could use the
on-demand model to load some data even
some of our larger data sets
and try things out without having to
make any upfront commitment
um the operational overhead has been
significantly reduced
right now backups are automatic and one
of the things that our team really loves
is the ability to simply ask bigquery to
present a copy of a table anytime in the
last seven days
so if you're trying to validate a data
load issue that happened last night you
can simply ask bigquery to
present the copy of the table from
yesterday and you could take a look at
what changed
similarly if you've ever accidentally
dropped a production table and i know
none of us have
ever done that uh you could easily
undelete a table for up to three days
with a single sql command so there's no
need to run to the dba and ask for a
tape back up and you know have your
heart skip a beat as you think about the
implications of what's happened there
um bigquery kind of handles all of that
for us in a really easy
to use way um and finally with respect
to cost
again the on-demand pricing allowed us
to start things up
at a low run rate and then once we found
what we stabilized at we could basically
purchase reserve slots
and make sure that our cost was fixed
going forward that we wouldn't have
sudden spikes
so now i'm going to jump into a live
demo where i'm going to show how we
democratize data at mlb
and in this case i'm going to walk
through an example where we are going to
take a data set that contains data for
all 30 major league baseball clubs
and show how he would share it with just
one of those clubs uh while applying
security
to ensure that that club can only see
their own data i'm
going to jump in from the perspective of
a single club in this case the yankees
and show how that club is able to access
that data um
and even run queries with their own data
combining and joining with that data
to demonstrate how bigquery's data set
sharing and authorized views allowed us
to democratize data access at major
league baseball
i'm going to walk through a small
example here
i'm in the bigquery console logged in as
a major league baseball employee
so i have access to data across all 30
teams
for example here i've set up a small
dummy schema
of a tickets fact table that contains
one row per ticket sale transaction
as major league baseball we have access
to all 30 teams data
and one of our goals here is to ensure
that we share that data with each of the
30 clubs so that they can make their own
local business decisions
so the goal would be to share the giants
data with just the giants and the white
sox data with just the white sox
in our first iteration of wheelhouse
data sharing we accomplished this
by setting up 30 copies of the data each
day so we would run queries
to segment out the data and pull all of
the giant's data and put that in one
file
then we'd pull data for the white sox
and put that in another file this
involved making copies of the data which
incurs issues when perhaps you have data
that has been updated later on after the
file was produced perhaps
other data synchronization issues and
just other challenges in
making sure that you stay in sync with
what you've copied out so with bigquery
this gets a lot easier
so to demonstrate this first of all
logged in as major league baseball i can
do a demo query to show
that i can run something like a sum of
the quantity
um from this table across all 30 teams
so as major league baseball
i can see the sum of the quantity broken
down by the team name for example
um and we can see that i do have access
here as major league baseball to all 30
of the club's data
so now if i want to just share data with
the yankees for example we should be
giving them access to just the slice of
the data pertinent to them
the way we accomplish that is by
creating a data set that we share data
with the yankees in
assuming one doesn't already exist i can
go into bigquery's console
and simply set up a data set that we
will use for sharing with the yankees
and within that data set i'm going to
create a view and this is a standard sql
view
that's just going to say we're going to
create a view of next demo yankees
tickets as select star from
the parent data set where the
team name is the yankee so we're just
going to say where the team
name is equal to yankees so this is a
standard sql view
um and we'll see that it gets created
and we can check it out that the dbl
is available here for us and it's our
pretty traditional sql view
um where it just gives access to that
slice of the data
most data warehouse systems and database
systems do not allow you
to share access to the view without
sharing access to the underlying table
and this is where bigquery's authorized
view differs so
normally i couldn't share this view
without actually giving access to the
entire base table
which we wouldn't want to do because we
want to give the yankees only access to
their subset of the data
so all we have to do here to enable this
functionality is on
our parent data set set up the
authorized view to say that this new
view that we've created in the child
data set
is authorized to access the parent data
set so in this case here we're going to
say that the next demo yankees view is
authorized to access the next demo sales
the parent data set
with that in place all i now need to do
is figure out who i want to share the
data with
and this works very similarly to google
drive or
google docs sharing where you simply
provide a list of g suite email
addresses or g suite groups
for this demo i'm going to be using just
a single dummy
email address i set up but in production
we actually use
g suite groups to enable entire groups
of users at a time that are managed
locally by the clubs so all i have to do
to share data is give it a list of email
addresses that i want to share with
so i'll use my dummy email address here
of yankeestaff gmail.com
and i tell it that i want to give access
just to view the data not to modify it
not to modify the ddl
it's a read-only access that i'm
providing here and much like
any other sort of google switch uh
sharing that's it we're done
so now we can see that we immediately
have given access to
um a set of users or a user so i'm gonna
switch gears here now i'm gonna switch
over my browser window to see what the
yankees would see i'm logged in here on
this
browser window as the yankee staff and
initially i would have had access to
perhaps nothing
if nothing had been shared with me yet
from major league baseball centrally
but if i refresh my screen now i have
access right away to
that data set that's been given to me
here so i have this ticket data set here
and i can start running queries on it
right away for example the same sum of
the quantity that i was running
on the parents data set i can run here
all the same
and i'll see here that as the yankees
user i'm only getting access to that
slice of data that's pertinent
to the yankees so in this case here it's
just that 10 000 rows
um what makes this even more powerful is
that i can bring my own data
that i may have locally and not shared
with major league baseball
and i can join that across these data
sets so there's no barriers here
of data silos where data's in different
data sets can't be joined
if you have access to data no matter
what the data set is you can join across
it
so uh for my example here let's imagine
the yankees have a small
local sheet of promotions they are
running and they want to analyze which
of those promotions generated the most
sales
so if this is a sheet they may have in a
csv uh
they could go ahead and use bigquery's
ui to very easily upload that data from
the csv
we point to that csv we give it a table
name here we'll call it promos
and we'll tell it to automatically
detect the schema and just like that
within a few moments there we will have
a table created for us locally
this would be a table that the yankees
have access to that otherwise is not
shared anywhere else
now uh the join could be written that
combines those two things together so
i've
written this query up here that says
let's take the data that major league
baseball would have shared with us in
the tickets data set
and we're going to do a join with the
promos data on the game date
and this will allow us to run that query
that crosses those two data sets and
sees which promotion has the highest
overall quantity sold
so in this example here we see that the
highest quantity sold was a t-shirt
that led to the most quantity sold other
than no promotions which were there
because perhaps
we didn't fill in all the promo data so
you can see how this paradigm of being
able to join across data sets you're
authorized to
allows you to have different access
patterns for data
while still allowing centralized
querying across them thanks rob and
thank you for joining us for google
cloud next be sure to check out some of
our other great data analytics sessions
thank you
you